Ron there's an old statement I've read
and heard about people saying in
Congress the banks never lose I think
that's a general statement I think the
big bankers never lose thought I think a
little banker right then I was losing a
lot because a lot of little bankers are
getting closed down the big banks are
gobbling them up I don't think David
Rockefeller is gonna lose I don't think
he's gonna be out selling apples or
pushing pencils anytime soon but a lot
of bankers that are being wiped out that
the state level are losing but the big
banking power structure seems to have
control because they're on the inside
and they have control of money and they
know what policy is going to be down the
road can you specify this structure that
you're talking about this power
structure well the power structure
basically is made up of a lot of very
powerful business and corporate leaders
in the country and it's in particularly
they have formed their organizations
they've been around for a good while and
they don't even hide it anymore you know
the trilateral committee Commission as
well as the council formulation no
matter what which president which party
is in power they will appoint to the
major offices members of these two
committees and they're always they they
always have control of the federal
reserve system so the Wall Streeters the
big bankers have inside information as
far as what is happening what's going on
and control over money is pretty
significant because if you can control
money you're really controlling one half
of every single transaction so that is a
tremendous amount of power but it
doesn't look like we're gonna have any
independence they say that Federal
Reserve is independent but that's a
bunch of nonsense the protection that
the founders gave us to try to keep us
from this happening never authorized a
central bank and they were very strict
in the writing of the Constitution to
limit the power of Congress to only to
the minting of gold coins to allowing a
no Ling gold and silver to be legal
tender in prohibiting the printing of
paper money all
those things we have failed to follow
that's why we have a central bank with a
paper money system and a lot of
inflation high interest rates in a very
very shaky economy so I would say that
if we would have followed the advice of
the founding fathers and not allowed
this power structure this group of
elitist bankers and industrialists who
get control not only of the banking
system in the monetary system but really
our foreign policy and our government I
wrote a little speech and gave a speech
right before I left Congress and I said
I don't think the members of Congress
would really know how little effect they
have in controlling things really this
and that means that the Congress that
itself doesn't have much control the
people doesn't have much they don't have
much to say about it either the control
of overall policy is really in the hands
of a very small number people who
control all the administration's all the
appointments to cabinets and certainly
all the appointments to the Federal
Reserve that shows we have a single
party political system in the United
States just maybe split into a little
bit but there's I see it's a single
party and if you look at the obstacles
put in our way as libertarians get on
ballots it's it's an outrage because we
have to spend more than a third of our
energies and our monies just to apply to
get on state ballots and in this
distracts us some states it's almost
impossible you know they say and I have
not personally investigated every law
around the world but they say that we
are one of the toughest countries in the
world to get a new party assistant an
American people been conditioned that
it's great to have two parties we don't
want to be like Italy where there's all
these choices we want to limit our
choices it's easier that way and we
don't want to be like Soviet Union where
there's only one party yeah that's right
so they have to but if policies never
change what's the difference so we do
have one party there's policies never
change you know if there would have been
a difference maybe under the Republicans
we would have had a closer to a balanced
budget
but the deficits were worse with the
Republicans but foreign policy the
policy of intervention subsidizing
communism and helping rich allies that
always continues Republicans and
Democrats
it was the same policy Republican or
Democrat that supported wars like Korea
and Vietnam and the CIA
operations in the FBI all these
operations are endorsed by the by the
other two parties but in that for that
reason what do they do they could
control the funding as well the other
two parties get over a hundred million
dollars handed to him you know not too
long ago we had the two conventions on
national television Republican
Democratic convention and the American
people didn't watch they should have
they paid for it they paid nine million
dollars we as citizens were forced to
pay to run those conventions nine
million dollars apiece and therefore
they get all this exposure making it
again very difficult for an option a
third option to be heard it's very hard
to get our message out but the control
is there whether it's in the political
control or the banking control or in
government policy control in the
administration